[Música]
el asesinato de un alto científico
nuclear iraní a amenaza con aumentar las
tensiones en oriente medio'
teherán advirtió que responderá en el
momento y la forma adecuada además de
acusar a israel de ser un mercenario de
eeuu medios israelíes informaron que las
embajadas del país están en alerta ante
el temor por posibles represalias
disidentes cubanos logran diálogo con
representantes del gobierno de miguel
díaz canel tras una manifestación
pacífica frente al ministerio de
cultura- en contra de la censura y la
represión funcionarios aceptaron
encuentros periódicos con los
manifestantes para solventar sus
diferencias el hecho marca un precedente
histórico en el país las autoridades
indagan si diego armando maradona
recibió la atención adecuada justo antes
de su muerte mientras las muestras de
cariño siguen llegando desde distintas
partes del mundo hoy en el estadio del
napoli continúa el homenaje a la leyenda
del fútbol enlazamos a la ciudad
italiana con nuestra enviada especial
hola buenos días en américa latina y a
todos ustedes que nos siguen por la
señal de france 24 mi nombre es alan
austria sean bienvenidos
empezamos en irán el asesinato del
destacado científico boxer aclysa de
amenaza con aumentar las tensiones en
oriente medio teherán que acusa a israel
de la muerte advierte que responderá en
el momento apropiado a los hechos según
informan medios locales las embajadas
israelíes están en alerta por posibles
represalias el científico iraní a quien
las potencias occidentales catalogaban
como el cerebro detrás de un programa
secreto de armas nucleares murió el
viernes en un ataque que incluyó al
menos una explosión y tiroteos a las
afueras de la ciudad de teherán israel
no se ha referido al tema mientras irán
dijo que la onu se reserva el derecho a
defenderse ante cualquier ataque eeuu
declinó hacer comentarios al respecto
así advirtió el presidente de la
república islámica sobre una eventual
respuesta a los hechos
hamer lux man on irán todos los enemigos
de irán tienen que saber bien que la
nación iraní y los funcionarios del país
son lo suficientemente valientes e
intrépidos para responder a esta acción
en el momento oportuno los funcionarios
pertinentes responderán a este crimen
en la última década varios científicos
iraníes que trabajaban en el sector
nuclear murieron en ataques atribuidos a
israel por parte del gobierno iraní
vamos a algunos de los hechos que han
tensionado las relaciones entre ambos
países a través de los años
una nueva víctima que se suma a una
larga lista poseen farixa de es el
quinto científico nuclear iraní
asesinado en 10 años todos han muerto en
ataques similares tiroteos o coches
bomba
el renombrado físico masud ali mohammadi
profesor de la universidad de teherán
muere en la explosión de una motocicleta
bomba frente a su casa 11 meses después
majid shahriari un actor clave en el
programa nuclear muere en un ataque
bomba
mahmud ahmadineyad entonces presidente
iraní acusa a israel ya los gobiernos
occidentales de estar detrás de estos
ataques
washington y tel aviv niegan su
participación los asesinatos más
tuvieron lugar en los años siguientes
así como intentos fallidos hasta el
acuerdo nuclear iraní de 2015 en 2018 el
año en que donald trump anuncia la
retirada de eeuu del acuerdo nuclear los
servicios de inteligencia israelíes
confiscan miles de documentos secretos
sobre el desarrollo nuclear iraní para
el primer ministro benjamin netanyahu
esto es una prueba de que irán busca
adquirir armas nucleares dice que muchos
en fariza de es el cerebro de este plan
una parte clave del plan era formar
nuevas organizaciones para continuar el
trabajo así lo expresó el doctor
en fariza de jefe del proyecto iraní
amada recuerden ese nombre farixa de el
asesinato podría exacerbar las tensiones
regionales en un momento en que eeuu se
encuentra en plena transición
presidencial
donald trump sigue siendo el jefe del
ejército estadounidense hasta el 20 de
enero según el diario the new york times
a principios de este mes
trump consideró atacar un centro nuclear
iraní nos vamos a cuba donde artistas
que se manifestaban contra la censura y
la represión lograron un diálogo con
autoridades del gobierno luego de una
protesta pacífica el hecho marcó un
presente histórico en el país donde no
existe el derecho de facto a protestar y
son pocas las veces en las que el
gobierno acepta hablar con sus
manifestantes información de matías de
res
más de 150 personas se reunieron en el
ministerio de cultura de cuba este
viernes para mostrar su solidaridad con
los artistas disidentes que se enfrentan
a la represión del estado lo que
queremos ver primero una garantía a
nuestras libertades la libertad y que
sólo se escuchan nuestras demandas que
tienen que ver con vivir en cuba sin
sentir temor por como pensamos hacer
arte en cuba sin que eso constituya un
peligro para seguir siendo antes hace
unos diez días varios disidentes
iniciaron una huelga de hambre para
rechazar el encarcelamiento del rapero
de ni solís este jueves las autoridades
rompieron la huelga y detuvieron a dos
personas más a raíz de esto nació la
manifestación del viernes que comenzó
con dos docenas de personas por la
mañana y que fue creciendo a lo largo
del día incluyendo a artistas de
renombre internacional como tania
bruguera y fernando pérez
y los manifestantes exigieron un diálogo
sobre los límites de la libertad de
expresión y lo que llaman represión
estatal los disidentes lograron reunirse
con representantes del gobierno donde
acordaron encuentros periódicos para
dialogar sobre sus diferencias un logro
histórico en un país donde no se respeta
el derecho a manifestar y son pocas las
veces que el gobierno acepta un diálogo
con su contraparte
chile ayer vivió una nueva jornada de
protestas en santiago de quienes exigen
la renuncia del presidente sebastián
piñera y la liberación de detenidos
durante las manifestaciones del último
año cientos de personas se congregaron
en las calles cercanas a la casa del
gobierno fuertemente acercado por la
policía se presentaron choques entre
manifestantes y las fuerzas de seguridad
que emplearon gases para dispersarlos la
policía informó que destinará 1.100
efectivos para responder al llamado a
protestas durante este fin de semana
el ejército de etiopía tomó el control
de nuevas ciudades en la región de tigre
en medio de intensos bombardeos que
continúan hoy en su ofensiva contra los
rebeldes el líder de las fuerzas
rebeldes confirmó que avance el asalto
contra mekelle la capital de la región
el primer ministro aviv ahmet dijo los
enviados de la unión africana que no
quería mediación en este conflicto y que
no hablara con las fuerzas regionales de
tigre hasta que se rindan o sean
derrotados pero agregó que su gobierno
está comprometido en la protección de
los civiles
se estima que por el conflicto más de 43
mil refugiados han huido a sudan
mauricio jaramillo docente de relaciones
internacionales analizó para france24 si
esto es el comienzo de una gran crisis
humanitaria en áfrica
sin duda alguna y yo le recordaría a la
gente que esta es una zona que viene
golpeada por dos coyunturas muy muy
críticas en primer lugar hace unos diez
o doce años estábamos hablando del
genocidio en darfur que provocó lo que
era en ese momento la peor crisis de
refugiados que tuvo el mundo y que ya
había impactado la zona tenemos además
de eso la salida constante de personas
que huyen del régimen de seguías
afeworki en eritrea y además esta es una
zona que colinda con el sahel en donde
recientemente ha habido ataques de
grupos de terroristas de fundamentalismo
islámico entonces es muy grave que ahora
a esa coyuntura crítica de los últimos
años se sume una crisis en uno de los
países más estables del cuerno africano
como como lo era etiopía yo creo que mi
ciudad
ni somalia ni egipto ni en general los
países circundantes a donde podrían
llegar los refugiados eritreos están
preparados para la salida hasta ahora de
40 mil personas pero cuyo número se
puede disparar en las siguientes semanas
las autoridades argentinas indagan si
diego armando maradona recibió la
atención médica adecuada justo antes de
su muerte en la mañana del miércoles
mientras las muestras de cariño siguen
llegando desde distintas partes del
mundo el cuerpo técnico que trabajaba
con él en gimnasia y esgrima renunció en
bloque en solidaridad con el astro
argentino además la fifa pidió a sus 211
federaciones de fútbol guardar un minuto
de silencio por la leyenda futbolística
en sus próximos partidos hoy en el
estadio en la póliza ubican bufandas
velas y mensajes para rendir homenaje a
la leyenda del fútbol
allá en el sur de italia se encuentra
nuestra enviada especial natalia ruiz
natalia te saludamos como transcurre la
jornada
muy buenos días pues en realidad los
homenajes a diego armando maradona
continúan y van a continuar por mucho
tiempo porque esta ciudad vive
difícilmente este duelo los siguen
llorando y seguramente lo van a llorar
durante muchos años como ustedes lo
decía así es la gente estuvo en el
estadio hasta pasada la medianoche de
este viernes dejando banderines dejando
banderas mensajes ahora estamos aquí a
las afueras de nápoles aquí en este
lugar el club nápoli saverio vignatti y
aquí en realidad hay uno de los más
grandes tesoros que pueda tener esta
ciudad y es que hay exactamente como un
museo dedicado a maradona con cientos de
objetos unos más increíbles hay que los
otros objetos que el astro argentino
utilizó cuando vivió aquí en annápolis
cuando llegó aquí entre en 1984 y antes
de que se fuera aquí de aquí de nápoles
en 1991
natalia de cómo va el proceso del cambio
de nombre del estadio del napoli que
pasará a tener el nombre del astro
argentino
pues es un proceso que va a tomar un
poco de tiempo porque en realidad según
a la ley italiana se necesita que la
persona haya muerto diez años hayan
pasado diez años de la muerte de una
persona para que un sitio para que un
monumento un lugar pues se lleve el
nombre de esta persona puede ser que
este proceso se ha acelerado en todo
caso pareciera que las autoridades aquí
quieren que así sea en todo caso tanto
el presidente del club del napoli del
nápoles como el alcalde de la ciudad que
nunca se han podido entender entre ellos
en lo político en este caso si han
encontrado un digamos han encontrado que
están de acuerdo en cuanto a esto en
cuanto a que el estadio sampaoli pues
pase a llamarse estadio diego armando
maradona por ahora no hay digamos unos
tiempos de cuánto va a durar este
proceso seguramente va a ser acelerado
porque lo que sí es cierto es que todos
a una polis tanos quieren que este
estadio lleve el nombre de su héroe
natalia ruiz muchas gracias por tu
reporte en nuestra enviada especial a
nápoles en italia y ahora que la carrera
por la vacuna contra el kobe 19 se
acelera la uem se lanza una alerta por
la situación en los países africanos
organización explica que el continente
no estará listo para afrontar una
vacunación masiva esto debido a las
dificultades financieras y logísticas en
esta región
en momentos en que la comunidad
internacional saluda la eventual llegada
al mercado de prometedoras vacunas las
autoridades sanitarias africanas alertan
que el continente podría sufrir las
desastrosas consecuencias de esta
carrera liderada por los países ricos
sabemos que los países africanos están
inquietos y esperamos que la reserva de
millones de dosis de vacunas por los
países ricos no les suponga una
desventaja para el acceso a los
tratamientos y soplas el continente
todavía no está listo para desplegar una
campaña de vacunación a gran escala los
principales obstáculos el costo y la
logística de las operaciones el acceso a
1,5 millones de dosis estimadas para
vacunar al 60% de la población africana
necesitaría una inversión de más de 5.5
billones de dólares un coste estimado
que corresponde solamente a la compra de
las vacunas a lo que habría que sumar el
precio del material almacenamiento y
distribución y que podría elevarse
considerablemente si fuera necesaria una
segunda campaña de vacunación
aunque disponemos de vacunas que son
efectivas o que al menos parecen serlo y
que tenemos la previsión de
de manera masiva no se debería frenar la
investigación y el desarrollo de nuevas
vacunas todavía no sabemos cuánto tiempo
durará la inmunidad de estas vacunas que
están por llegar amigo la semana pasada
el número de casos de coronavirus
confirmados en áfrica superó los 2
millones y la oms advirtió que el
continente se dirige hacia una segunda
ola de infecciones en este momento se
han efectuado alrededor de 21 millones
de test en el continente africano que
cuenta con más de 1300 millones de
habitantes
anoche los estadounidenses vivieron un
black friday bastante inusual a raíz de
la pandemia la tradicional fecha que en
años anteriores estuvo marcada por
largas filas y multitudes que buscaban
aprovechar las ofertas estaba este
limitó sólo un pequeño número de
personas en cada tienda quienes
decidieron evitar aglomeraciones optaron
por las compras en línea se espera que
las ventas por internet alcancen una de
sus mayores cifras en la historia con
más de 10 mil millones de dólares
y finalizamos con deportes y un pesaje
muy particular en el boxeo no sólo por
esa barrera que separaba a los rivales
sino por el hecho de volver a ver a mike
tyson y a roy jones júnior
preparándose para un nuevo asalto esta
será una exhibición en donde están
prohibidos los nocauts algo que ha
levantado muchas críticas serán ocho
asaltos en dos minutos en los que los
aficionados tendrán la oportunidad de
volver a ver a sus dos leyendas del
pugilismo en acción
llegamos al final de esta emisión les
agradecemos mucho su compañía los
invitamos a que siga con nosotros en
france24 ya que no baje la guardia
con el kobe 19 siga con nosotros
[Música]